that's the whole deal you've kind of
given me an aha moment willie too like
the next time i
am in a relationship maybe i'm gonna
treat them like a toddler
hi it's time for another art of the
interview where i speak to my fellow
hosts about their work and legacy to get
deeper insight into what they do and why
they do it and who better to speak with
than morning joe co-host and host of the
emman nominated show sunday
today with willie geist and there's to
the today show i mean what don't you do
i don't i try to just i go for volume
like quantity over quality just always
just always be on tv maybe people will
take you seriously
for a minute i mean seriously though
because i
never stop and it's like i drive myself
kind of into
a prolific hole on a daily basis and i
wonder why i'm tired and burnt out and
i'm spread so thin what is it for you
why don't you stop
because first of all i love it i feel
lucky i feel grateful that i get to
to do this job i feel on the one hand on
morning joe like i get to be on the
front lines of
the news literally at 6am you get the
first bite at every story and set the
tone for the day
and you know we've been doing it for
almost 14 years morning joe
and so we've created a space where
people come you know politicians show up
and that's where they want to make an
announcement or
talk about what's happening in the news
and then on the other hand the sunday
show was a little bit different which is
that is just something like you in here
i just started from
you know a concrete slab and built it up
from there
where i get to write all the copy and
sort of have
more of a creative say in what happens
morning joe is just about the news you
know what that show's going to be
sunday today because it's once a week we
kind of curate it
and craft it and we'll start it on
wednesday and then work out on thursday
better on friday and finish it off on
sunday morning yeah so
it's the balance of you're in the weeds
of politics of morning joe and then on
sunday
you get to take a little deep breath and
do interviews with interesting people
like you and all the people i get to
interview
how do you work in the realm of politics
but then come
in sunday morning neutral yeah like that
how do you
not have the baggage and yet get to be
an authority over here that's an
interesting dance
it is an interesting dance and it's not
always an easy one and i think what
happened particularly in the last five
years as you say even on morning joe
by stating a fact or speaking something
true
you offended some people who maybe
supported the president
so you know cable news is so
siloed into okay msnbc is for
progressives fox news for conservatives
cnn maybe
tilt's lap but maybe closer to the
middle i try just not to be that person
there are enough people with opinions or
enough people screaming about the news
or enough people who enjoy
the cat fights and everything else that
happens on cable news and i just don't
really participate in it i try to inject
information i try to ask good questions
sometimes those will have within them an
opinion
because that's just you know a statement
about what's happening
in that story but i try not to be
the raging opinion guy in morning joe
because there's plenty of that already
so i think my job is to just cut through
that with a politician or again if it's
just our roundtable of people talking
it's like okay guys we're really making
a lot of assumptions about
what everyone who just woke up at 608
a.m
understands about the story so i'll just
kind of bring it down to the level of
all right what are we talking about here
what's going on exactly what are the
views of this story
i can try to just try to lay a
foundation of
facts okay do you do that at home
well i try not to interview my wife too
do you take that art of assessment
and apply it to your family i think so
yeah i also
i have a great wife christina who is
that way as well she's
she i want to marry her she's she's
great she's she's amazing
she doesn't need a lot of assessment
like i feel like she always has her act
together
you know what i mean i just have such a
great partner you know i really do and
it's a
it's a true she runs two companies she's
two startups
um and she puts her heart and soul into
those and she's amazing at that but the
minute she turns that switch off
she's back and she's with us and she's
running the show so it's funny people
like oh you're so busy how are you doing
like i actually know my wife is so busy
and so that makes both of us respect the
other's time
to pick up where the other ones not you
know need some help why do couples have
such a hard time with this
because i hear you guys say if i'm
absent this morning i will have the
evenings or
definitely i've got this you've got that
and you kind of make an
agreement why does this salute so many
couples
i don't know christina calls it not
keeping score so
she's not gonna ever say well you
weren't here this morning i took the
kids to school
so you need to do that it's just i think
it's understood it's like an instinct we
have for each other
and i also know she's not like sitting
around watching the real housewives all
day she's like
busting her butt working she doesn't
need me coming i'm like oh i'm so tired
she's like yeah i'm tired too
so just see that in somebody or if she
looks a little stressed or something's
going on with business i'm like
i can just see it we don't have to say
anything i'm like guys let's go for a
walk let's go to riverside park or just
you know just pick up pick each other up
a little bit that's all
well it's funny as parents you know that
a little
environmental change will do wonders for
a child why don't we think about that
for each other as romantic partners
brene brown said that
her and her husband will give each other
like an i'm at 30. i'm at 40. okay
together we've got 70 yeah
who's pulling that extra 30 and dividing
we know that's the discrepancy
it sounds so functional you guys are
adorable you're cute you're sexy you're
funny
and you guys met when you were kids yeah
we were 11 years old
we met in mr kaplan's homeroom at george
washington middle school in ridgewood
new jersey
we had just moved from the other side of
town so i was the only kid
i didn't know any of the other kids at
the school and i was sitting alone in
the middle of the room because and i
swear as god as my witness
looking at christina i was like hmm
she's cute
i was 11. i didn't know what to do with
that you know it was interesting
and she's like yeah i kind of remember
you were kind of like tall i looked like
anthony michael hall in the vacation
movies kind of gangly you mean rusty
rusty oh of course i was rusty that was
my look
that was my body type it was all it
wasn't great you know
but we were friends we were friends
through high school we were friend you
know we ran in the same group
and i think that's what she always says
when you have a basis of friendship
first and there wasn't all this like
romantic pressure first
that's we already knew each other we
already trusted each other so we were
friends middle school
and most of high school then the end of
high school we start dating
and then i was going to vanderbilt in
nashville
but she was already into vanderbilt so
she calls me that summer hey we're going
to college together and we're
like kind of thought this was a high
school relationship we went to college
together
and you had already been dating already
been dating so you're like wait a minute
my
college experience is about to get
dampened totally with christina
lurking around and not a huge school so
we were going to run into each other
and we tried to break up the freshman
year we did break up
and there's some funny names in our past
like oh you still think about so-and-so
right we went on one date with um and
then we did get back together
but then we broke up in our 20s when we
graduated
um college christina moved to boston i
moved to atlanta
and so we kind of had our 20s as single
people which is another
i think in hindsight was great for the
relationship
you know listen i'm happy to stay home
with the kids every night because i went
to studio 54
and every disco on the planet thereafter
it's true i
i think if you actually live your life
then you might not put it all on another
person
and we have the basis of friendship i
think has given us
not only trust but honesty from the
beginning so when we
start a fight or if i'm being a jerk or
something which i try not to be
she will just say in that moment like
you're being a
i'll use the word jerk but that's not
what she would say i think i know and
she just goes right to it and then
starts with a d
yeah or an a d usually though okay yeah
and i'll just start with three yeah i
am that that's right i am and so we call
each other out quickly
so it doesn't fester and it's not a
thing of like we've been in a fight all
week we have the fight
and in the moment we settle it and
identify who was the jerk
and then move on haitians aren't just
the you know
problem at hand i think it's ego too how
do you
handle your ego to listen to her in that
moment agree
laugh and come down to the level because
i respect her opinion enough to know
that
there's no ego here what i mean i was
wrong she always laughs that
she can tell like with a toddler that i
haven't
that i need some rest or some food
i'm 45 years old and she's like let's
get you some food
yeah like if i'm being the d she'll be
she won't be like i can't believe you
should be like
let's get you a little food okay and
let's have the talk in about 30 minutes
i'm like what are you gonna tuck me in
for the nap too i mean you're hoping so
yeah yeah exactly i could use a little
sleep and a snack
what is a good piece of advice to
couples to not
lose perspective on how important that
respect and encouragement is of your
partner
you have to always have it it always has
to be there it just has to be your
guiding principle
and and look we're it's not a perfect
relationship we do have fights and we
have disagreements and we have lulls and
all the things that people have but
if you come back to that baseline i'm
not here and you're here
that we're both on the same level if
that's always in the back of your mind
i don't have to work very hard to do
that because she has my respect
and i do think she's amazing in ways
having nothing to do with being my wife
or even the mother to my kids but
she just does great things with her life
and i have huge respect for her and
that's
that's the whole deal you've kind of
given me an aha moment willie too like
the next time i am
in a relationship maybe i'm gonna treat
them like a toddler
because who doesn't need a little
tuck-in
and a little snack that's true but also
the core wisdom there
is if you do this hot under the collar
in the moment
you're probably going to regret it
exactly so let's roll it back let's dial
it down
it's it's higher road approach yep and
i'm so glad that you guys
do that for and with each other yes and
she's always right in here she doesn't
get too high
or too low which is like that's another
thing that's nice there's no like
volcanic moments necessarily drama is so
hot when you're young and so
not right and i do appreciate that your
family
and you as an individual seek humor and
levity
and do you find that that is an antidote
for you
having to present the world every day to
everyone as it's happening in real time
which we all know how hard the news can
be
absolutely that's i think that's another
key with the respect and the honesty is
a sense of humor about everything
i mean sometimes i say she'll say you
need to go eat other times she'll just
laugh in my face
like you are ridiculous i love her
that's so
you're being ridiculous and just laugh
and then i start laughing and it's over
it goes away and the kids are always in
here they pile like ooh
dad's a little worked up i'm just like
oh man
i'm outnumbered here but she's i'm lucky
i'm lucky
just want to say it since this is the
art of the interview you do such a good
job because
you are so curious and i think you don't
follow a script and i'm the same way
when i interview someone people can give
you
question areas or whatever it is but
just follow where it goes
you have such genuine curiosity and
empathy and openness and
to interview you is a joy like i was
talking about before i
you know i ask you a simple question and
you just it makes my job
so much not only easier but it's such a
joy to have somebody like you who just
is like here it is i got nothing to hide
and maybe somebody can learn something
from this thing i'm telling you right
now
and so i'm just so happy that this is
going so well for you the show
congratulations it's true you hope
someone will dance and yeah
i studied you and christina so much that
i was like now i can just have an easy
conversation
because i learned a lot about you guys
and
i do think you can't be too wrote and q
and a
no it it has to flow um i don't think
that comes
without a ton of research and then
throwing it away
yes and going kind of on your memory so
you're not out there as i said before
naked and afraid
yes which is how i would feel if i come
to something ill-prepared
i am my i have rats in my stomach yes
it's so funny you say that because my
son had a science presentation a couple
weeks ago and he was nervous
oh gosh i said preparation crushes
anxiety
if you're ready if you know it inside
and out
the anxiety slips away and that's how i
feel about my interviews i don't want to
go in and wing it and be like i didn't
read too much what's this movie you're
in
i want to know everything i could know
because then i can
if it's not going the way i thought i
can go to a different place or i can
react with a reference that
enhances the conversation so just be
ready just be prepared
have a little outline in your mind and
go i think we have a new mug in the
making it says
pca preparation crushes anxiety
i don't know how many light bulbs i can
have go off in this time with you but
another one just
not went off but burst and exploded into
fireworks
pca preparation crushes anxiety
thank you what an honor and a privilege
thanks for having me drew